governor steve sisolak announcing our
statewide pause will continue through
the start of next year
we do thank you for joining us tonight
i'm sasha loftis
the i-team's david charns is live in the
newsroom now with everything
you need to know so break it all down
for us david well sasha the governor
making some big headlines here he is
extending our statewide paws
and restarting an eviction moratorium
that pause going through january 15th at
the earliest
those are the restrictions limiting
capacity at restaurants and casinos to
25 percent
and that eviction moratorium going until
march of next year now that allows
people to stay in their homes as we all
continue to deal with this pandemic
now this all comes as cases
hospitalizations and deaths continue to
rise here in southern nevada
they are actually higher now than they
were three weeks ago when the pause
started
governor sissel acts saying more
restrictions could be put in place
if things get worse but i need to be
clear
if officials and experts agree that our
trends are going beyond our ability to
respond
i will be forced to come in front of you
all again with tougher actions
i believe we can avoid those actions if
we all commit to it
now the governor also saying a shutdown
is quote unrealistic
he blames congress for not providing
additional support
and also says our families and neighbors
need to have a place to stay
and try to remain healthy we also talked
about that covid vaccine it's
on the way to us right now and the
governor expects first doses to get out
tomorrow
i asked him what he would say to people
who have to wait
and what he'd say to those who don't
want it
the vaccine should be here tomorrow and
i would have no problem
whether it would be my mother my sister
my kids my wife anyone
getting the vaccine i'm confident in the
safety
and the efficacy of the vaccines it
would encourage people
to take part and receive the vaccine now
as we've reported those in nursing homes
and health care workers will get that
vaccine first
likely in the next week but otherwise
healthy adults may not get vaccinated
until spring or
summer the governor is asking us to be
patient and continue to do what we're
doing until
it is safe now the governor also calling
on washington to give more help to us
he warned returning to a full stay at
homeowner sort of
what we saw in the spring he said he
doesn't want to do that
and he said it would be quote as bad or
worse
than the great depression live in the
newsroom tonight i'm david charns 8 news
now